[Music]
I have seen gods fly I've seen men build
weapons that I couldn't even imagine
I've seen aliens drop from the sky
yeah but I have never seen anything like
this
how much more you hiding
[Music]
yeah hold
[Music]
my son it is your time
you get to decide what kind of thing you
are going to be
don't please
[Music]
cuz we
because we own you
I waited my entire life for this the
world's gonna start over i'ma burn it
all
what happens now
determines what happens to the rest of
the world
[Music]
[Music]
is the world more peaceful since a
revolution it is a shame that your
people suffered but bounty hunting is a
complicated process
they said you were coming
they said you were the best in the
Parcak would you agree
and then tellurium
look outside
they are waiting for you
yeah good
some the Galaxy will be remade
[Music]
the Jedi and Republic
we'll guy I sense a plot to destroy the
Jedi
we must take why would anyone walk away
from being a Jedi we were trained to be
keepers of the peace
not soldiers
we clones
have mixed feelings Carter war
without it we wouldn't exist
I'm part of the plan plan everything is
about to change
[Music]
every choice made
[Music]
has led to this
[Music]
lady why am i alive you are a toy you
belong to Bonnie these are your friends
woody I have a question um well actually
not just one I have all the questions
who wants to go on a road trip you need
help with that no no I got it
now this is a little strange but we all
have to make sure nothing happens to
four key buzz we gotta get quite Roger
that change of plans
Jesse buzz hey watch it
Oh let's go save us spork do I need to
be worried
my guys are veteran so hang in there
Oh
I know the perfect toy to help
do kaboom Canada's greatest stuff man
oh yeah posing yeah do quick hold on one
more oh yeah you'll save me I've known
that guy my whole life
today's
[Music]
is that how we look on the inside so
much needs for kids
Oh sheriff would you always come into
the rescue
that's gonna be quite a jump for you and
Duke for me
[Music]
let's kaboom
before he's being kept how do we get
that key what about the old plush rush
there you go oh where did you two come
from well we're not doing that
you jakesully I'd like to talk to you
about a fresh start on a new world you'd
be making a difference
[Music]
give me marine for the hardship I told
myself I can pass any test that man can
pass all I ever wanted was a single
thing worth fighting for
ladies and gentlemen
are not in Kansas anymore you're on
Pandora
you should see your faces
they're beyond that fence we have an
indigenous population called the Navi
this is why we're here because this
little gray rock sells for 20 million a
kilo their village happens to be resting
on the richest deposit and they need to
relocate and you're supposed to be
finding a diplomatic solution concept is
to drive these remotely controlled
bodies called avatars they're grown from
human DNA mixed with DNA of the natives
marine did inhabit our body I some won't
mix you get me what I need I'll see to
it you get your legs bent your real legs
yes sir looks like you this is your
avatar just relax let your mind go game
shouldn't be heard for you
[Music]
Jake it's real simple
I want you to learn from the inside I
want you to gain their trust
[Music]
you should not be here
[Music]
this is your fault I need your help
[Music]
outstanding
haven't gotten lost in the woods have
you you forget what team you're playing
for strong prey on the weak nobody
doesn't say you've got one hour
we knew this would happen changed Jake
it's crazy here before Rich's taking
over he's bullying guess you better stop
there
[Music]
they've sent us a message that they can
take whatever they want but we will send
them a message
but this
there's over left
Cassie was like a thousand years ago I
fought my way out of that cave became
Iron Man realized I loved you
and we said no more surprises but I was
really hoping to pull off one last one
the world has changed
all we can do is our best and sometimes
the best that we can do
[Applause]
[Music]
I saw a hole these people died
I keep telling everybody they should
mean gone
someday bananas
even if there's a small chance
we owe this
everyone who's not in this room to try
[Music]
we will
whatever it takes
[Music]
Reverend Tex
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
I like this one far away as north as we
can go once stood an enchanted forest
you see an enchanted forest yes it was a
magical place but something went wrong
since then no one can get in or that was
added
[Music]
what would I do without you you'll
always have me
[Music]
how's Ella seemed weird to you she seems
like Elsa there's this voice voice what
does that mean
the kingdom is not safe find who is
calling to you they may have answers I'm
going with you
Anna no excuse me I climb to the North
Mountain survived a frozen heart and
saved you from my ex-boyfriend so you
know I'm coming it's normal
where are we how did you get in the
forest then this party for her has
compatible where did you learn magic
[Music]
can't you follow me into fire and don't
run into fire
[Music]
magic is very alluring without you she
may lose herself
protect arendelle at all cost
[Music]
I believe in you Elsa
or anything
quick question is the hole putting up
the mortal danger gonna be a regular
thing
being a street dog isn't so bad at all
he's a tram I'm free to be whoever I
want to be walk wherever I want to walk
Hey hi are you two UH twins I'm our
husband pal aha eat whatever I want to
keep he's a chair just remember I got
this the old-fashioned way I stole it
snob hell there we go I got my color let
me just take a little guess here you're
the center of your peoples universe
right well that's basically all over now
you're about to be replaced replace me I
don't think so lady this is Lulu
when the baby moves in the dog moves out
[Music]
help me get this thing off I'm sorry
this is not awkward at all
this way totally safe I'm not gonna do
that
keep it crazy you don't know that happen
[Applause]
what is this place
in a great big world out there
with no fence around it
[Music]
every day could be an adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
did you wash your hands with soap did
you dry them all vegetables wanted all
vegetable I did so are we going to talk
about it what the elephant in the room
what elephant moms new job
it's time to make some wrong things
right help me bring supers back into the
sunlight we need to change people's
perceptions about superheroes and
Elastigirl is our best play better than
me I'll watch the kids no problem do it
dad they wants to do it I don't know
that way why would they change math math
is math math is math hello hey honey
kit everything's great
and direct track he's an excellent
health is freaky you know it's crazy
right to help my family I gotta leave it
to fix the law I gotta break it you got
to destroy kids can have that choice
thank you young man
combustion imminent what does that mean
it means fire Robert
the screen sledder interrupts this
program for an important announced that
it might get weird I'll be there ASAP
[Music]
I hope you're ready it'll be here any
minute is that a rifle you don't know
what a rifle looks like it's just swords
were your thing and guns were mine but I
guess we were both doing guns now I just
didn't know that
I see it within you fear jealousy
betrayal this is our duty to cleanse the
universe of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's saving the galaxy we're really
gonna be able to Jack about price it for
two time Galaxy savers
[Music]
[Applause]
sometimes but then you're searching for
your whole life it's right there by your
side all along you're right
[Music]
listen the mirror
after all these years I've found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad Peter
for generations this peaceful island has
been home to our family but beyond our
reef a great danger is coming
legend tells of a hero who journey to
find that demigod Maui
and together
they will save us all
Louanne
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
of the wind and ci0 of men what it's
actually Maui shapeshifter demigod of
the wind and sea hero of men I interrupt
it from the top
euro of men go back going on a mission
with some little girls did not see that
coming the ocean is a friend of mine
first we got to go through a whole
notion of bad Nakamura right
they're kind of cute
[Music]
got your back
it's Maui
really blow dart in my butt cheek we're
going to the realm of monsters don't
worry it's a lot farther down than it
looks
[Music]
when I heard that the high school or
high school musical version had never
staged a production of High School
Musical the musical I was shocked
inspired and triggered as millennial
auditions are after school I've seen
their original movie 37 times and the
first 15 minutes of those sequels it
would be insane to think I might
actually a shot at playing Gabriella I
know we're not a couple anymore it was
my idea to take a pause I didn't want to
take a pause I can't believe it she's
dating each 8th husband this is a
nightmare
I want audition for Gabriella Ryan right
I think you'd rather play Sharpay that
is so fresh I'm bummed that we don't
have any competition here she has to see
me in a whole new light I'm auditioning
for this thing tomorrow
and nothing is gonna stop me the cast
list is posted we have our Gabriella and
our Troy buckle up Wildcats it's about
to get real
I basically have zero chill about this
right half
[Music]
what are you doing here if she really
cared about me you'd but somebody who
wants to play this part played
you all walked in here as strangers but
after today you're a family I believe in
us
[Music]
excuse me is there some where you're
supposed to be Broadway
[Applause]
I'm intro this is officer McCord we got
a 10:30 flash is the fastest guy in
there you can run the plate right back
are you saying it because he's a sloth
he can't be fast flash flash
hundred-yard - buddy it's nice to see
you nice to see you - hmm
officer judy hopps zpd how are you I am
doing fine
well what hang in there can I do well I
was hoping you could run it for you well
I was hoping you today
well I was hoping you could run a play
for us we are in a really big hurry
what's the plate - nine number - 9 th D
0 3 - 9 t HD 0 3 h d0 3 p 0 3 0 3 a
flass one either a joke sure what do you
call a three humped camel I don't know
pregnant
we please just wait wait Priscilla oh
yes flash what do do you know why you're
here to me mistakes for me just so you
know what have you share with me in this
room stays in this room
this is a safe space sterile bugs bugs
listening devices Oh No
greetings fellow humans what you are
about to see is a historical record of
my life as a detective I live in the
shadow of this water tower in Portland
Oregon a place where things get strange
I am the CEO of my own detective agency
he's so fascinating I could show you
around the precinct sometime I don't
collaborate with law enforcement okay I
have a partner that's cold who's that
his aim is total he's a 1500 pound to
pull a barrel whoa
are you serious mother not now Timmy the
failure mobile commands the respect of
others it belongs to my mother who won
it in a church bruffett it was the key
to my success until it was stolen
mistakes were made
finding the failure Mobile is now our
top priority he's fired up today I know
I'm so excited
I need help you always get me into
trouble can I help you your life is big
original weird if you love what you do
you have to fight for it whether I need
more office space
my name is sillier kidney failure
the name is misleading because I am
anything but I am only concerned this
one saying
freaks
mistakes for me
[Music]
intelligence
stamina
courage in heart
my business is dogs
he's under sized is trouble
well good afternoon is untrainable
what does he bring to the breed the
heart of a survivor
he outran every single one of them he's
not a sled dog he's a lead dog
what we have in our children was an
epidemic the death sentence they found a
cure
round trip is 600 miles
you see that storm in the horizon only
one man and one dog can make that run
he's 12 years old he's too old he'll
never make that distance that when
warned you pumpkin
[Music]
my guess is we don't find him till the
fall
all right Togo time for us to find out
who we are
I always thought he lived for the sled
when all along what he lived for
was me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]